This video is brought to you by rake on air buds with great sound so at a great
price,
check the mouse by rake on.com forward slash biographics more on them in a bit.
At first glance,
it seemed like the most of the third was destined to become just a footnote in
history. Another name on a long list of Kings who once ruled over Egypt,
his father had been a media Curulla dying when the Mozo was only three years old
afterwards, his stepmother took power for herself,
and it would not have surprised anyone if the young Pharaoh's simply vanished
without explanation, but that didn't happen. In fact,
as a young man that Mosa learns and is trained in the ways of warfare
anticipating that one day, he would assume the throne and that he did,
and he immediately embarked on one military campaign.
After another always looking to increase the size and power of his
empire.
He only stopped when it became clear that Egypt was the single most powerful
nation in the region. And that his empire was the largest in the world.
Third was born circa 1481 BC,
and was part of the 18th dynasty of Egypt. The first one of the new kingdom,
he was the son of Pharaoh that most of the seconds and a secondary wife named
ISET. His name is alternately spelled Moses or mess.
Although these all appear to be Greek variants of his actual Egyptian name,
which was de drew who times, but of course,
as we learned in the Bible and suntan command of Pharaoh did not have a single
name. No, in fact, his Royal title,
he contained five names and each one possessed variations,
founds on different inscriptions and roughly translated.
That means the strong bull arising in Thebes enduring of the kingship,
like raw in heaven,
sacred of appearances and powerful of mite lasting is the manifestation of raw
thougth is born beautiful of form. And just say this video, isn't an hour long.
We're going to stick with the Mosa.
Normally the heir to the throne was the son of the Pharaoh with his great Royal
wife who in this case was Hatshepsut. However,
the two of them had only one daughter together, princess Neffer, uh,
whose ultimate fate remains a mystery. Therefore by default,
the throne went to th most of the third as he was his father's only son.
Speaking of Hatshepsut, we already did a full video on her,
where we talked about the complicated and uncertain relationship,
which he had with us steps on.
So we're not going to rehash all of that stuff right here.
Just to give you the cliff notes version that most of the second died when his
son was only three or four years old, he was too young to take over the throne.
So instead had Shep sort of served as his regions. However, after a few years,
she managed to assume full power becoming one of the few and arguably the most
successful example of a female Pharaoh,
the exact circumstances under which Hatshepsut took power from most of the third
are still a bit of a mystery.
When this event was first discovered about a hundred years ago,
scholars of that time branded Hatshepsut manipulator,
and to usurp up off to rule following the female Pharaoh's death,
someone tried to erase it from history and the most likely suspect would have
been a stepson.
The main reason he would have done this would have been if he harbored deep
resentment towards his stepmother, right? Well,
many modern historians aren't completely sold on this idea anymore,
mainly because there is no solid evidence to back any of it up. They're all,
no ancient documents or inscriptions to suggest that that Mosa ever tried to
rise up and take back power from Hatshepsut since the over yesterday outlived
her,
that Mosa would have had ample time to record his victory in the history books,
mentioning how he won back his empire from his evil manipulating stepmother,
the pharaohs recorded all of that trumps on all the last stat I and tomb
inscriptions. The facts that no such proclamation exists,
or at least has not been found yet suggests that maybe the relationship between
[inaudible] and most of the third was more amicable than scholars initially
believed after this.
The fact that [inaudible] attempted to raise you from history likely occur
decades after a death. So a more probable culprit,
which have been most his own son.
Amenhotep the second who may have done it to try and claim some of [inaudible]
accomplishments as his own. Lastly,
perhaps the most telling indicator that the most they felt no ill will towards
Hatshepsut was the fact that he ultimately became a ferric rule.
One of the service handbook is that you do not allow the person who you have
usurped to live. You can look at other examples in history,
and that person always met with an unfortunate accident or just disappeared from
the historical record.
What little evidence we have of that Moses early years suggests that he lived a
relatively happy and safe life under Hatshepsut.
He had been given an extensive education in anticipation of him. One day,
ruling Egypt.
He was not even kept under tight supervision as the young Al lived more with the
soldiers than he did at touch-ups its course and learning all the intricacies of
warfare plus skills,
such as hand-to-hand combat horse riding and archery to show her a complete
trust towards the end of our rain Hatshepsut even placed the Mosa in charge of
her armies though.
She had little interest in Congress and mainly use them secure the borders and
protects trade expeditions.
She seemingly did everything she could to ensure that when she finally died,
her empire would be left in good, strong and capable hands.
[Inaudible].
Hatshepsut died in 1458 BC going by the conventional
Egyptian chronology and that most of the third finally came to rule over his
empire. 22 years after he actually became a Pharaoh,
he took a decisively different approach to governing than his stepmother
mobilizing Egypt's army. Isn't becoming a mighty Congress. Of course,
he had the benefit of decades of peace and prosperity,
which allowed the Ambar to flourish and get rich up the most that would go on to
become agent de Gibbs'. The most formidable military leader,
expanding the empire to its greatest ever territorial extent.
Ancient RAC orders show 17 major military campaigns into foreign lands starting
with Moses first year as sole ruler.
And this does not take into account minor skirmishes or battles to defend the
borders. Well, we're not going to discuss all of the campaigns.
We will examine the most important ones and we will start off with the first it
was against the city of Maketto situated in a modern day, Israel,
it would lead to become a place of biblical significance because it was
mentioned in the book of revelation 16,
16 as the location of a great battle that would Mark the end times. However,
the city became much better known by its Greek name Armageddon and the 15th
century BC though,
the ghetto was part of a group of canonized cities that were under the hedger.
Many of the Pharaoh, they went all parts of Egypt,
but while hot shops had rains,
they paid tribute and sent over soldiers for our armies. However,
as is often the case when there is a period of transition of power mosquito
considered the death of Hatshepsut since the Ascension of Mosa,
as the perfect time to rebel,
hoping that the new Pharaoh would be less formidable than his predecessor.
That turns out to not be the case.
It is likely that either Mosa or Hatshepsut saw this move coming,
the Pharaoh was quick to mobilize his army to March on Maketto.
And according to his personal military scribe,
he covered 150 miles in 10 days out another day's rest. And in 11 days,
the Egyptian army arrived in Manhattan today called yadda.
Now the fortress city of mosquito,
the Egyptians were not only facing the people of Maketto as the city entered an
Alliance with another ancient Levantine kingdom called Kadesh.
The King of Kadesh also convinced other counter Knights sentiments to help in
that coalition, as well as the kingdom of Matana.
There were quite a few States in the area who were eager to see Egypt,
power and influence dwindle. They thought that this was the perfect opportunity.
Now that the nation was governed by someone young and inexperienced,
they planned to do everything in their power to keep the most as rain short,
but in the ends, they wouldn't get their wish. And yeah,
the Pharaoh conferred with his most senior advisors,
because he had to make an important decision.
He had to select the way by which she would approach McGee. Right?
You had a choice between three roads. Two of them were broadened in the open.
So traveling on them would be safe and fast.
The third was a narrow pass where it soldiers would have to walk single file and
would lead to his Vanguard, engaging the enemy in combat.
While the soldiers at the red still were traversing. The POS,
as you might expect, all his advisors recommended that the most,
they choose one of these safer roads,
but the young Pharaoh said this to his generals.
I swear as rah loves me as my father, Amman favors me.
As my nostrils are rejuvenated with life and satisfaction.
My majesty shall proceed upon this Aruna road. Let him of you wishes,
go upon these roads of which you speak and let him have you who wishes come in
the following of my majesty behold,
they will say these enemies whom rah abominate as his majesty set
out on another road because he has become afraid of us.
So they will speak unsurprisingly. After his speech,
all his commanders agreed to follow their Pharaoh.
The most then went outside and talked to his man about traversing,
the dangerous pass, promising them that he would be at the front of the column.
So the entire army traveled the perilous road,
but this proved to be actually a stroke of genius.
When they finally emerged on the other side of the past,
they found no enemies waiting for them. In fact,
the coalition never considered that the most they would take this road.
So now the interruptions had the element of surprise on their side.
The battle of Maketto most likely occurred on April the 16th, 1457.
The size of the armies can only be vaguely estimated,
but the historians believe each site had at least 10,000 men,
probably closer to 15 thousands.
We have the work subscribed that tells us how it went down. His majesty.
He went forth in a chariot of Electrum arrayed in his weapons of war,
like Horus, the smarter Lord of power, like Monteux of Thebes.
While his father among strengthens his arms.
The Southern wing of this army of his majesty was on a Hill South of the Burke
of kina.
The Northern wing was at the Northwest of mosquito while his majesty was in the
center with Amman as the protection of his members, the Valor of his lens,
then his majesty prevailed against them as the head of his army.
And when they saw his majesty prevailing against them,
they fled headlong to Makita and fear abandoning their horses and their chariots
of golden Silva. The people hold them up, pulling them by their clothing,
into the city.
The people of this city had enclosed it against them and lowered clothing to
pull them up into the city. The fare of his majesty had ended their hops.
Their arms were powerless. His sup and da-dum was victorious among them.
Now this account was clearly spruced up to make the most.
I see him as heroic as possible and refer to him as his majesty.
A lot that's described does mention a mistake on behalf of the fat rope.
Once the enemy had begun retreating, he did not press the attack immediately.
Instead allowing his men to plunge the battlefields.
If he would have engaged the fleeing combatant,
he could have ended the war right to then in that instead,
the soldiers retreated inside McGee,
which was a fortress and the most absolutely siege on the city.
The King of Kadesh had managed to make his escape. Meanwhile,
the Egyptians that no other choice,
but to wait until the people of mosquito ran out of supplies and surrenders,
it took seven or eight months before they finally exhausted all their food and
water and tapped to throw themselves at the mercy of the Pharaoh.
And indeed the most, it was actually pretty merciful by their standards.
Of course, he plundered Benito,
it's valuables taking tens of thousands of capital over 2000 horses and almost a
thousand chariots, countless weapons, laborers, and suits of armor.
But he did not burn the city.
He did not kill its population and he did not even execute the high officials
responsible for the insurrection. He did replace them with people loyal to him,
and he also took their children to be raised back in Egypt. In reality, though,
these children were prisoners in case their father has got any ideas of
rebelling. Again, I want to thank you.
Set in the wood rebel against is today's sponsor.
The fantastic Ray con who make these ear buds rake on make great earbuds
with great sounds at an affordable price.
By now they're all about innovative air by design at prices that don't break the
bank. They sent me a pair of these. These are the everyday easy 25 earbuds.
Now I've been using them for a couple of weeks, but just take one outset.
They fit very easily in the air and have quite weird shaped his for some reason.
So it's quite nice. Often other headphones, I'll be walking down the street,
they'll drop onto the floor yet to have that problem with these one.
Also you get six hours of battery life and the air buds or playtime,
I should say, in the elbows themselves.
Then you put them in this case and you get four more charges.
So I have not charged these up very regularly because it's
just so much charged held in this magically twenty-five case.
Now I've used expensive devices. I've used cheap earbuds.
What Ray can really do is they deliver a premium experience at about half the
price of other premium wadis earbuds.
So if you go to buy Ray con.com forward slash biographics,
you'll get 15% off your order and let's go back to today's.
[Inaudible].
It was far more than a victory against one city beside the fact that the most
eight now held a location with important strategic value.
His triumphant mosquito instantly made him known as a force to be reckoned with
in the region,
even so that mostly knew that his hold on cannon was tenuous of best.
The numerous other cities in the area might not have openly raised arms against
him, but there was certainly no friends of Egypt.
If he were to simply return home,
it would not be long before they would renounce his authority,
even openly rebel against them,
especially if aided by other powerful factions like Matana or Kadash holding
the Gita mostly did have an advantage besides its strategic value.
The city was also a vital agricultural center,
which provided a lot of food for nearby cities.
If the Pharaoh were inclined to wait until a Windsor,
he could simply have starved them into submission. He saw no need to delay.
He still had a strong army and fresh supplies.
So he continued his military campaign.
It has been estimated that throughout most his entire career,
he con good well over 300 cities, towns and other various settlements.
The others did not really benefit from a detailed accounts like that at the
battle of mosquito though,
as most of them simply had itemized lists containing the spoils of war.
Presumably this is partly because most of those people chose not to fight at all
and simply submitted to the Pharaoh anyway, from the Gita,
mostly traveled North following the course of the Leteny river,
there were still some cities like tar and sit on who were on friendly terms with
the Egyptians,
and they were glad to have them in the area helping to minimize the influence of
other nations. Kadesh in particular, according to ancient records that most,
they also built a fortress somewhere in this region.
It was cool to make a Hapa is the binder of the barbarians with the arrival of
autumn, that Moseley decided that it was probably time to return to Egypt.
Each new settlements. He conquers meant another Garrison,
which she wants to leave behind troops into ensure peace.
And this meant his army was starting to dwindle. On the other hand,
he was returning to thieves with over 7,000 captives.
These were not strictly slaves,
but rather unpaid workers who were expected to pay part of their tribute in the
form of free labor.
The following Springs that mostly departed Egypt again with his army,
but the next military campaigns mainly involved collecting tributes and only
occasionally putting down a new rebellion as a show of force was generally
enough to keep most of the other cities in check. Of course,
this didn't always work,
but mostly it was faced with a crisis when the city state of tuna revolted
alongside Kadesh and that vassals,
and also aided by the Matana who remained Egypt's most powerful folk.
The Ferrero had to react quickly.
And this time he was far more ruthless in his actions.
Ancient records stay that the settlements, which rebels were destroyed,
the city States of tuneup and Kadesh however were a bit more challenging in the
ends that mostly chose to attack tuneup Kadesh was a veritable fortress,
and the only way to defeat it was with a long siege and the Pharaoh didn't not
have time for one. When the entire region was close to insurrection,
tuneup was the easiest targets and it ended up being even easier than most I
expected because neither Kadesh tunnel Madani came to it Sade.
So the city had no choice,
but to surrender and accept what type of punishment the Pharaoh had in store.
[Inaudible].
Pretty clear to most say that he had to deal with the kingdom of Matana one way
or another for this. However,
the farrowing needed to find a way of traveling around 500 miles all the way
from Egypt across the Euphrates river,
with an army while keeping it fed healthy and safe enough so that it would be
able to find a powerful foe at the end of the journey. This was a tough task,
3,500 years ago, considering that a large army,
you could only average around 10 miles per day,
and that's not taking into account minor skirmishes that it would likely to
encounter along the way to achieve this goal.
So mostly needed a place that he could reliably use as a forward base of
operations and to foster method of transportation.
This was not something that the Pharaoh achieved in one go. In fact,
he fought the Bhutani for about half of his soul reign,
engaging them in one way or another. During at least nine military campaigns,
he continued to build fortresses further up North into his empire,
starting with the sixth campaign. He began approaching Kanaan by sea,
which was foster and allowed him to submit to the problematic city of Kadesh as
he slowly but steadily built up his fleet.
The mostly also brought the Phoenician port cities under his control to gain
access to that harvest.
Eventually the Pharaoh's strength in that area grew large enough that he was
able to cross the afraid to use river and as launched a surprise invasion on his
phone, capturing the major Italian city of Aleppo located today in Syria,
it was a huge blow for the Matana whose influence in the region decreased
significantly. They weren't wiped out completely,
but it became clear who was the major power in the region as an added bonus,
the nearby Kings of the Hittites Babylonians and the Syrians all gave gifts to
the most as tribute to show their submission.
It was arguably the most that's most notable military campaigns.
When he returned to Egypt, he commemorated his tribe by erecting,
a large obelisk, which can still be found today,
except that it's an Istanbul having been moved by Roman emperor.
Theodosius now speaking of the ABOs square,
mainly focused on that most of his military career today,
since that's what he's primarily remembered for,
but we should mention that he was also a prolific builder who commissioned over
50 monuments, temples and tombs during his reign, if nothing else,
that mostly needed all those extra walls and columns.
So video space to record all of his military victories,
the place that benefited most from his attention was the vast temple complex
located today near the modern city of Locksaw best known,
simply as contact the most. They did not found it,
but he added more constructions to it than any other Pharaoh,
mainly to the temple of a moon. Even today Karnak is famed for its John pillars.
And is one of the main reasons why Luxor is dubs?
The world's greatest open-air museum.
[Inaudible].
The Pharaoh's we'd like to complete that mostly story by looking at what
happened to him after he was turned into a mummy,
the most of the third died in 1425,
BC aged 56 under unknown circumstances, his son Aman hotel,
the seconds became the new Pharaoh wealth at most say it was buried in tomb,
KV 34 in the Valley of the Kings as burial location is part of the raw cash,
which is today a complex of tombs that contained many Pharaoh's Royal wives,
princes, princesses,
and tiny priests from the 17th to the 21st dynasties unsurprisingly.
Most they wanted to be buried there because it was the final resting place of
his father, grandfather and ancestors.
The downside was that this was a very well known area and the tombs were
subjected to very heavy looting and desecration meant that most of those mommy
was first unwrapped in modern times during the late 19th century,
French Egyptologist guest and Ms.
Sparrow noted that his mummy had been torn out of the coffin by robbers who
stripped it and rifled its, if the jewels with which it was covered,
injuring it in that haste did carry away the spoil.
It was subsequently reentered and has remained undisturbed until the present day
as mother had suffered extensive damage. In fact,
it was among the worst conditions. Any mommy recovered from the raw cash.
This wasn't helped by the fact that it was removed unwrapped and examined using
19th century technology, which probably made things worse only has had,
was intact and remains intact at the Kira museum.
But scholars still noticed that it did not show the image of manly beauty with
intelligent features depicted in his statutes,
but rather someone whose forehead was abnormally low,
the eyes deeply sunk the jaw heavy,
the lips thick and to the cheekbones extremely prominent. But of course,
none of this mattered at the end of the day that mostly made Egypt a dominant
power wants more and forged the largest empire in the world's record.
He kept for almost 800 years. So I really hope you found that video.
Interesting. If you did, please do hit that thumbs up button below.
Don't forget to subscribe also. Please do check it off.
Fantastic sponsor Ray com special discount link below this video.
Thank you.